[Music]
legacy
this week's 48 hours investigates the
possible role of a common item found in
medicine cabinets in the death of a
millionaire
when steve clayton was found dead at his
south carolina home
investigators did not suspect foul play
at first
but the behavior of his wife lana
clayton raised suspicion
in 48 hours correspondent peter van sant
says a test
led to a startling discovery
a police body camera was recording as a
grieving lana clayton
was comforted by a friend
lana a nurse said she found her husband
unresponsive
at the bottom of the staircase as word
spread about steve's death
from an apparent heart attack his nephew
nick french
rushed to the mansion she gave me a big
hug
started crying when did you start to see
things that troubled you
right away she made no mention of
attempting to revive him
steve's family reached out to coroner
sabrina gast
and asked for an autopsy and a
toxicology
test the results revealed an unusual
chemical
in steve's blood tetrahydrosaline is the
common ingredient in visine
the eye drop the eye drop
tetrahydrazalene
a common ingredient in many brands of
eye drops
is extremely toxic if swallowed
solicitor kevin brackett was the
prosecutor in this case
can it create a heart attack it can lana
clayton was brought in
for questioning um there's a drug called
tetrahydrolazine
immediately she knew exactly what
tetrahydroxylene was
oh okay this is really odd on august
31st
2018 lana clayton was charged
with her husband's murder and i did not
kill my
husband wow peter van sant joins us now
peter what would have happened
if steve's family had not requested the
toxicology and autopsy
well this case would not have been
solved it would have been seen as a
fall down a flight of stairs and a heart
attack
and also the wife wanted stephen to be
immediately cremated but the family
got the autopsy which resulted in a
toxicology report
that discovered this poison and it needs
to be said that the manufacturers of
these eye drops say
they are safe if taken as directed i use
some this morning
it is for external use only and is to
never be swallowed
thank you for adding that i did as well
peter van sant i appreciate it and you
can watch peter's full report